[Music]
look at that you guys from bedazzle
looks and snazzy suits to vibrant hues i
mean the 2022 cmt awards red carpet
fashion did not disappoint country
music's biggest stars showed up and
showed out and the clear color trends of
the night very spring pink and purple
gail king was just one of the stars who
hit the carpet in bright magenta all
glammed out in a blingy jumpsuit
i know what's good on you gail who are
you wearing who are you wearing because
i thought for the for the cmts you have
to wear something sparkly yeah mark
bauer just made this for me in like
24 hours he sure did she looks amazing
she was there to introduce monica little
big town and jimmy allen before they hit
the stage for their performance jimmy
also shined on the carpet in his purple
suede fringe moment if you look closely
you can see his shoes match his jacket
and we gotta talk about the ice my man
did not skimp on the jewelry check out
his sparkly diamond chain with matching
bracelets he's got the earrings to match
the rings four diamond rings and that
watch
goodness give me some of that blade
man now here's the thing carrie
underwood up the ante too in this
perfect get what i did there
animal print chain mail mini dress
complete with this matching manicure
that she posted to the gram now
backstage husband mike fisher he was on
purse duty tell us
wants to know about your
thank you
uh dolce gabbana official purse holder
it's so good gonna be the official purse
holder uh co-host and performer kelsey
ballerini outdid herself with six looks
and she had to serve them from home
after testing positive for coven hey are
you sure you're really sick because you
look amazing this is just my
my normal monday night sitting around in
like full glam
she started the night on her own pink
carpet rocking this white michael kors
tuxedo in her driveway of course her dog
dibs had to get in on the action
when you can't make it to the carpet so
they bring the carpet to you
anything's possible y'all in side note
girl even did her own glam her makeup
artist posted this clip coaching her on
zoom
running out of the bathroom just changed
did the eye it is time for performance
the last look
aka
my pjs and a lemon shirt because i feel
like we made lemonade out of lemons
tonight
mayor and morris started off the night
comfortable as well
and she switched out those black
sweatpants for this custom rosario look
complete with a sparkly bra top and red
fitted skirt with a train now she joked
on instagram that she was giving
unintentional bodybuilder but wow she
looked incredible from head to toe do
you see her arms i mean talk about goals
pythons also maddie from maddie and tay
she was giving this disco ball realness
check out the glittery floral mini dress
that she rocked on the red carpet with
her husband jonah i styled myself
tonight and you are looking beautiful
thank you and leanne rimes called her
look from last night's carpet goddess
work she's stunned in a white and silver
george chakra gown
i'm giving you diamonds and
you look angelic thank you so much
oh oh
you're having a shoe it's somewhat
angelic yes it is
[Music]
and last but not least carly pierce she
made us green with envy in this emerald
sequin dress and owes the fans no
apologies for this high sl high slit leg
moment little poison ivy action come on
i mean riley green you know he was like
all right come on now carly
out ditch yourself thank you yes you did
meanwhile breeland was a first time
nominee at this year's cmt music awards
he showed up on the pink carpet wearing
a green wrangler casey jones button up
utility pants and mcqueen shoes he
topped off his look with a stainless
steel necklace and earring but his best
accessories were tanya and girard my
parents are here your son
is spectacular thank you get in here mom
the breelan in the house y'all
it's a family affair and i'm telling you
is this where you got your fashion sense
from
you know i would say
they did i
y'all did more than all right they did
fantastic are you just so pumped to see
your sun shine i'm so excited this is a
really really wonderful opportunity for
him